huge news weekend and I'm glad you're
with me today because we're now seeing a
sort of front and center the
consequences of having a clueless and a
sort of ADHD tendency president
specifically when it comes to war in the
military we already saw the consequences
of an ignorant ADHD president with
Obamacare with tax cuts with immigration
with diplomacy with North Korea and many
other areas and now we are seeing it
with war because Donald Trump approved a
US military strike in Iran against Iran
as retaliation for Iran as far as Trump
believes shooting down an American drone
this would have stepped us effectively
into war with Iran but then Donald Trump
called it off last minute this was
happening right planes were in the air
ships were in position and then the
command came to stand down these would
not have been strikes on Iranian drones
Trump approved of striking a bunch of
missiles and radar sites our ally the
United Kingdom was told about our plan
ahead of time and not told about the
cancellation until almost three hours
after the cancellation took place why
was the strike cancelled Trump says
because he found out how many people
would have died in that strike tweeting
quote on Monday they shot down meaning
Iran an unmanned drone flying in
international waters we were cocked and
loaded to retaliate last night on three
different sites when I asked by the way
I mean this is just a mess first of all
cocked and loaded it's locked and loaded
i someone emailed me and said cocked and
loaded is a gay porn film i didn't
verify that for myself but it sounds
like it could be how does no one tell
trump that it's locked and loaded and
then he's talking about different sites
si ghts of course he means sites and
locations which is a different spelling
when I asked how many will die 150
people sir was the answer from a general
10 minutes before the strike I stopped
it not proportionate to shooting down an
unmanned drone I am in no hurry our
military is rebuilt new and ready to go
by far the best in the world
sanctions are biting and more added last
night Iran can never have nuclear
weapons not against the USA and not
against the world
this completely erratic ADHD foreign
policy is a danger and an embarrassment
we're bombing people we're not bombing
people all without even understanding
anything and having caused this problem
himself most importantly and now this
has really brought some bad faith
right-wingers out of the woodwork
because the discussion from some on the
right has been wait a second you
anti-war lefties are now criticizing
Trump for not bombing Iran this is the
most bad faith discussion that I could
imagine I mean just shut up seriously
you don't even deserve a seat at the
table if that's going to be your
argument the problem is not that Donald
Trump didn't bomb someone and I wanted
them bombed
I don't want Trump bombing Iran in the
same way that I don't want Trump getting
involved in Venezuela or whatever else
the problem is Trump created this
situation he has no idea what he's doing
he ordered a strike without initially
considering the civilian casualties and
then last minute he's told a hundred and
fifty people will die and then he says
oh well let's not do that as opposed to
asking in the beginning about civilian
casualties civilian casualties if it was
a make or break for Trump which do we
believe that it was I don't know but if
it was a make a break for trunk Trump
it should have been asked about upfront
the absurdity and the cost of launching
this only to later discussed the
discussed casualties and then call it
off is ridiculous it's embarrassing and
it's pathetic now there are other
possibilities if you don't believe that
civilian casualties is actually the real
explanation for Donald Trump calling
this off one general one is is this some
kind of 4d chess by Donald Trump where
he is wanting to convey willingness to
do this but then canceling it because he
doesn't want the political repercussions
and he gets all the benefit of bombing
Iran without the actual civilian
casualties no evidence of that no
evidence that Donald Trump is even
capable of that type of abstract thought
so I don't buy that one the second idea
that's being floated and
gonna dig into this more tomorrow is did
Putin get in touch and say don't bomb
Iran and that actually could relate to a
lot of different things I want to
discuss with you
one component is the idea this actually
goes back to the Marshall Plan of the US
and Russia working together on nuclear
with Saudi Arabia being involved by
putting a ton of money and ultimately
getting nuclear technology out of the
deal because there is a long-standing
there's a history about Saudi Arabia and
nuclear weapons in the context of Russia
and Iran and the idea is that Trump
backing out of the Iran deal to get Iran
to restart enrichment to justify
attacking Iran could all be a backdoor
way to justify getting nuclear weapons
for Saudi Arabia into the region the
Saudi Arabian royal family have
previously said if Iran gets them we are
getting them so this is another entire
idea as well but again I've not seen
evidence that Donald Trump is capable of
that type of abstract thought wouldn't
be required if Putin or whoever just
said don't don't do it don't bomb Iran
and this there's a there's a interesting
growing theory that ultimately Donald
Trump despite his threats will not
attack Iran and will not get into
Venezuela and will not do anything more
in Syria because not doing anything
there in all three of those places would
be what Putin would want but we'll talk
about that and analyze that more
tomorrow so here's what I came away with
from this entire fiasco over the weekend
as center-right as Hillary Clinton is
and was and as much as I wanted someone
much more progressive and voted for
Bernie Sanders in the 2016 Democratic
primary consider that on three major
bullet points alone we would be much
better off with Hillary Clinton than we
are with Donald Trump and this goes I
know that most people in our audience
understand this but there are still some
people some stragglers remaining in our
audience who are of the Hillary Trump it
makes no difference to me sort of thing
Hillary Clinton was going to stay in the
Iran deal which Iran was complying with
which means Iran wouldn't now be
resuming Iranian enrichment and she
would not have ordered a strike on them
and then called it back like none of
this would have happened with
Ron if Hillary Clinton had been
president number two Hillary Clinton
would have appointed two center-left
Supreme Court justices who would now be
on the court for decades
rather than two right wing nuts like
Donald Trump is done that would have had
decades of political implications we
would have been exponentially better off
under Hillary Clinton than Donald Trump
and then number three Hillary Clinton
would not have willy-nilly started a
trade war with China while cutting taxes
on the rich and corporations period yes
Hillary Clinton would have done things
that I would not have liked yes Hillary
Clinton would have done things that
would not have gone nearly far enough
she would have done some sprinkling of
crumbs while the cake stays mostly in
the same hands much like Joe Biden would
do but on those three issues I just
mentioned alone trade the Supreme Court
and this Iran stuff we would be so much
better off right now under Hillary
Clinton than we are under Donald Trump
disagree with me changed my mind
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show and we
have just a massive program today I will
be talking about after the break about
what is incredibly a debate there's a
debate now over whether caged children
should have soap and bedding okay that's
a debate that is taking place in our
country right now thanks to the Trump
Justice Department I will also talk to
you about these very disturbing
revelations that Donald Trump threatened
a reporter with prison over a photograph
and then later on in the program there
are new rape allegations against Donald
Trump barely covered in yesterday's
Sunday shows I'm going to get into that
and I have a 47 second video for you 47
seconds of video that exposes the real
Donald Trump I'll explain all of this
later on huge news weekend and I'm glad
you're with me today